au fond il s'est passé des choses ces
dernières 72 heures des événements que
vous avez commenté les uns et les autres
pourquoi est ce que dans l'actualité un
des événements les plus graves n'a pas
été à la une
moi ça me révulse que des enfants
accueillent christiane taubira avec des
bananes en faisant le cri de la guenon
ya des gens en france qui dresse des
enfants à faire ça est ce qui est très
étonnant c'est que ça n'est pas fait la
une de l'actualité est ce que c'est pas
aussi grave que les autres débats qu'on
a un qu'on a eue ce week-end et voyez ce
qui m'inquiète beaucoup
c'est que justement cet événement là
était d'une certaine façon pas
totalement mais banalisés alors que
c'est une gravité extrême